a world of old traditions and
constant innovation this is what makes
europe a global leader in so many fields
from automotive to
agri-food or for example from pharma to
fashion
all across the world made in europe
means top quality today
i would like to talk about what we are
doing
to accelerate the recovery and make
europe even more competitive
the pandemic has led to an unprecedented
risk disruption of our single market
this should never happen again
this is why we are working on a single
market emergency instrument
another lesson we have learned is our
dependency on certain raw materials
sourced from only a handful of producers
green and digital technologies currently
depend on a number of scarce
raw materials we must diversify our
supply chains
this is the goal of our action plan on
critical raw materials
this is why we have proposed to create
a european raw materials alliance
and as we speak we are working to update
our industry strategy
our strategy is still designed to ensure
that industry can lead
the twin green and digital transition
but what has changed is both
the speed and the scale of this
transformation
and we need to make sure that our
industry
does not only keep pace with that change
but it should also drive it this
requires significant
public and private investment
with next generation eu we have a
historic opportunity
to provide the public funding
but we also know that public investment
cannot work miracles on its own we have
put forward
a taxonomy for green investment
and a green bond standard and in the
coming months
we will present more detailed rules to
help
you finance the transition
towards carbon neutrality so that
investors
can take fully informed decisions
in these months as we have fought the
virus
we have explored new ways of working
with european industries
building new and agile alliances
where the public sector joins forces
with industry
i want europe to invest in this approach
building new alliances and partnerships
with the private sector
for example our battery alliance
makes a very good story this is
how europe should always work
we shouldn't just work for our industry
but with our industry